[Music]
hey you guys
it's monday yeah we're doing slithes
so this is some [ __ ] ridiculous [ __ ]
this this was this is recommended by our
friend angel she was over here and she
was talking about slithers she scared
her when she was a kid yeah she said she
saw if you weren't here yesterday uh our
friend angel was here saturday
and she said that she had seen this at
the drive-in when she was a kid
and it had scared the crap out of her
and gave her nightmares but she hadn't
seen it since then
and i told her i said that
title sounds kind of familiar and i saw
it so it was on to be so i said oh we're
gonna we're gonna watch that and we're
gonna talk about it and see what scared
little baby angel
um
it was film i i couldn't really tell you
yeah
this movie was filmed where i was born
in california this is film where my mom
grew up it's in venezuela venice
california my mom went to venice high
and everything her family was from
virginia but they moved there when my
mom was a little girl and all her
sisters
and i happened to be born there but
moved away i guess in 1983 never went
back but this is the california i
remember remember that architecture
i remember some of the filming locations
where the oil refineries were they
weren't really refineries they were
refining coke which is like
shale
yeah not like cocaine not the exciting
stuff they were thinking about they had
oil pumps out there and big oil reserves
for crude oil and fuel
uh some of that [ __ ] blew up later on
had a big little oil tanker blow up out
off the coast when i was a kid i
remember when that happened it was like
an atomic bomb going off boom
we were [ __ ] 30 miles away and it
busted out some of the windows on the
damn block of where we lived it was it
was intense
we didn't think that was like 1977 or 78
been a long time knocked the christmas
tree over we had a christmas tree up
christmas tree started falling my dad
jumped up out of the damn
cat uh out of the chair he was watching
tv boom it went off in the [ __ ]
christmas tree started falling and i was
sitting on the ground he jumped up and
grabbed the christmas tree standing
right back what was that
went outside and everybody was standing
out there going what the [ __ ] was that
some people had busted out windows
and a few minutes later on television
just showed a damn super tanker out on
fire
probably about 15 miles off the coast
long beach
50 miles from us
is intense but i just
watching a movie kind of brought me back
to that air to that era and that place
uh the movie itself
pretty [ __ ] ridiculous
[Laughter]
basically it's a nuclear version of
[ __ ] creature from the black lagoon
yeah you could tell like the director of
this whose name is i think it's steven
traxler
um i think he only made one other movie
uh murder hornet pointed out yeah this
goes by two titles it's either slithes
which is what it is if you see uh on to
be like the title but the actual movie
is usually i feel like it's imdb page
it's spawn of the solitus yeah which
actually kind of makes more sense but i
don't know either way
but uh yeah so
we were we were recognizing the couches
all the decor
headboards
[ __ ] afghans [ __ ] that your meemaw
have [ __ ] your meemaw given to your mom
and [ __ ] [ __ ] just
so many macrame planters yeah
man
i know every time back in time every
time i see a movie that was made this is
this came out in 78 so it was made in
77. so this was made for a hundred
thousand dollars in 1970s money uh and
it was made in less than two weeks
um okay one thing i'm gonna say
for a movie that only costs a hundred
thousand dollars the monster looks
pretty good yeah um but you can tell
that
i mean they were really uh
padding out lots and lots of time
lots of conversations lots of sitting
around talking about it
kind of like let's just sit around and
talk yeah let's sit around
kind of like 50 sci-fi where they're on
the phone in the office talking to
somebody else on the phone in the office
well yeah it's like that we can't afford
to like show the monster like all this
[ __ ] yes we can always talk about it
yeah so let's talk about how we're gonna
like solve the problem of the monster
yeah do you know what movie that's
reminded speaking of the 50s monster
movies this movie the premise of it
reminded me of horror of party beach
because in horror of party beach which
actually i wouldn't recommend watching
it on its own because it's terrible but
the mystery science theater episode of
it is good
um it also had a thing where uh some oil
coming or something like that like
dumped some [ __ ] radioactive waste
into you know the ocean or whatever and
the radioactive waste made
the it kind of like made all these
little creatures like grow around
skeletons and stuff and turn them into
monsters this is that's kind of like the
same thing that's going on here it's
kind of like a radiation
it's a radioactive silt
from a reactor right and then it gets in
the water and then it's sort of like
is sort of like organic but also
inorganic one of the scientists says at
one point i'm like okay those are two
opposite things but whatever and uh
and it kind of like makes
new organisms somehow they just make
pulling [ __ ] out yeah it's just whatever
technology is whatever type of
ass so so this is kind of like creature
from the black lagoon slash
horror of party beach
kind of that's what it reminded me of
the one shining moment of this movie is
they introduce a character i'm going i
know that dude i know that dude and then
click
i recognized him
if you ever seen blade runner when
[ __ ] deckard goes to the damn
nightclub to meet rachel he goes to
taffy lewis's place and he meets taffy
it's up at the bar and he goes so you
ever uh you ever buy snakes from the
egyptian and [ __ ] teddy because
what taffy said what to tell you pal you
know david drake anyway he's in this
movie a guy who played taffy and he is
chewing all the scenery that's right and
he's got a long [ __ ] scene one long
scene where he [ __ ] just yeah he's
only once he's like a detective yeah
he's like a cop or whatever and he is
just but honestly like as soon as his
scene came on
yeah and he was just like wait i mean
he's like he had his eyes are rolling
around and he's like really uh you know
overly like uh you know pronouncing
everything he's very
kind of over the top and i was just kind
of like yep there he is there's my
favorite character yeah
yeah
that actor's name is high pike by the
way yeah oh remember like the guy that
played the um
the ship captain and you kept saying
where have i seen him he wasn't in a lot
but he was in uh thx 1138 so that might
be where you saw him before because you
because he kept looking at him going
goddammit i know that dude and i'm like
he was i thought he was the merchant
marine captain um in uh
uh raiders of lost ark the one is like
uh dr jones how much for the white woman
remember him he's smelling her yeah
trying to i haven't seen that tried to
buy and tried everybody looked like
she's not for sale yeah i thought it was
him but it's not hey step off don't be
buying my girlfriend well they were at
sea you want to try by a woman
you know you're on international waters
he's like well you know i just thought
i'd give it a whirl yeah you know what i
mean how about you
[Laughter]
but yeah so this movie
i mean i'm not gonna lie like i said the
monster looks cool it's kind of it's a
it's a cool premise i mean it's a very
it's kind of like a 50s monster like
radioactive monster movie like crossed
with like a you know 70s ecological type
thing
so that's kind of interesting yeah uh it
kind of uses the kind of skeeziness of
venice in the 70s to its advantage
but i will say
what it's a lot of the scenes are like
really
boring yeah but
interestingly there's some weird [ __ ] in
here too let's talk about this one scene
i mean basically all it is
is
uh you know right around venice there's
uh the first thing that happens is like
a bunch of dogs turn up mutilated
and the cops are clueless and they just
think oh it must be like the [ __ ] you
know off-brand manson family or
something like it's ritualistic or
whatever
and uh but what ends up happening is
that
i guess like a couple people get killed
and mutilated and then this guy
who is a high school journalism teacher
it's high school right he's a high
school journalism teacher his name's
wayne
and he is just over this whole teaching
thing he's like why did i even get into
teaching i hate children but you know he
doesn't say that but he's kind of like
you know he doesn't like the students
and he wants to get out of it so he
thinks if he can get to the bottom of
what's actually going on with this story
then maybe he can do like a freelance
thing and i don't know when a pulitzer
or whatever the [ __ ] now interestingly
so he thinks there's something else
going on behind this other than like
cult mutilations or whatever because he
talks to this bum
that saw the monster
and there's like a whole thing and so
mostly it's about wayne
the high school journalism teacher doing
an investigation into who's like killing
and mutilating these dogs and then the
people
interestingly he goes like when these
two people get killed
he is able like
pretty much it's the next morning right
i don't think they tell you that it's
not the next like after the murder
happened he goes to the house where
these two people got killed no crime
scene tape no police presence no nothing
he just walks into the [ __ ] house and
starts poking around at the [ __ ]
crime scene there's just like blood all
over the floor
and everything and i'm just kind of like
uh okay and so he finds
this weird mud or something like in the
cr the crime scene
so uh so he takes it to i guess a
science teacher at the same high school
whose name is dr john it kind of looks
like jim henson a little bit i kind of
and he talks real funny too he talks
like a like a human wouldn't talk i
don't know it's hard to explain he talks
kind of like
um
oh he he talks kind of like a high
school student's term paper he talks
like that so i guess they were like
that's how a smart person talks i guess
because he's supposed to be a scientist
so the scientist does an analysis on
this silt and then does some kind of
like digging and everybody finds out
information like really easily in this
movie and he's like oh yeah back in like
wisconsin or wherever the hell um there
was this radioactive [ __ ] or like a
nuclear power plant meltdown or
something and it got in the water and it
made this stuff called slithus and it's
like top secret and it's kind of like
this mud but it makes
it can make organisms but they're like
well so far it wasn't anything like it
didn't make monsters or anything like
that it just made like other little
bitty
or whatever but apparently now there's
like this big [ __ ] monster running
around so it's basically just kind of
like wayne investigating like going and
interviewing bombs going and talking to
the science teacher
and inexplicably wayne's girlfriend wife
girlfriend i guess her name is jeff
and well because at first
they said her name and we have the uh
closed captioning on because i'm deaf
right
so
i was like i thought that he said jess
or something and then i was like wait
it's on there it says jeff i'm like is
her name jeff and tom's like no it's
it's jess or something but no her name
is absolutely jeff and they don't really
explain they just make kind of like a
funny comment about it like you know why
is this like this and then uh you know
the scientist says here well why did
your parents name you jeff and i'm just
kind of like okay i mean i kind of feel
like they could have done more with that
joke i'm not really sure where they came
from um
as i was watching it i think most of the
most of the dialogues had lived
because they were all if you didn't it
might be they were they were goofing on
the dialogue while they were given the
dialogue they were yeah and then dudes
would just pull a joke out of their ass
but it'd be pretty good
it's because guys goofing on the movie
as they're making it it's just a bunch
of scenes strewn together they weren't
really taking it seriously yeah yeah
and um they're like well what has to
happen in this scene is this and that
they're just kind of ad-libbing it um
it kind of worked it's just kind of like
a movie that you would make with your
friends
yeah and have a monster in it
um
i don't want to say they weren't taking
it seriously the quality of it the way
it's filmed is pretty good
but for 78.
you know what i mean i've seen much
worse it's just um
i think the script was kind of flexible
they're just driving around their
friends that's a nice way of putting
they're just driving around to different
locations and uh putting their friends
in this movie and trying them and trying
to make it into a story
i gotta say that the locations are
pretty good though
they'll uh you know pretty nice
interiors from houses
houses from the 70s
uh some of it looks like
stuff from i don't know i might have
been in a shopping mall or a hotel some
of it
um
it's it's
it's just a scene movie
you can tell it's made by friends
like let's make this movie yeah they're
in the movie business okay it's like
that i kind of feel like it and like i
said for a hundred thousand dollar movie
um the monster suit actually looks
pretty good you don't get to see much of
it until the end like you see it a
little bit in the beginning but then you
know you don't really get to see it
until like the third act
uh can we talk about this extended
sequence because as i said it's mostly
about wayne and it's kind of about his
investigation so it's mostly him going
and talking to people and like finding
out information you know he charters a
boat and they go out and take soil
samples and all this other stuff so like
i said it kind of reminded me of horrors
of party beach in that way which is just
a lot of people like walking around
but it has that but then there's this
one bizarre sequence it's pretty long
it's like 10 minutes or something
and it's two characters that have not
been in the movie previously and
obviously won't be in it after because
they get killed spoiler alert but so i
mean they're just lining up for canon
fodder i guess so they set it up it's
this kind of skeezy old dude
with
the wonderful clothing combination you
know because the 70s his slacks are they
salmon pink
i don't know i kind of felt like they
were sammy pink and then he had one of
those like kind of brown leather jackets
that were all the rage back then
um older dude he's probably in his 40s
he's at this bar
where they're inexplicably having
a turtle race oh yeah over this now one
of the turtles is wearing a cocktail
umbrella on its back right this is not
explained
um
so they haven't had one i mean yeah so
they have these turtle races at this bar
and this older dude picks up this girl
who's 18 and she's visiting
and they're going to go back to his boat
that he lives on that's the best one
yeah this is the best part yeah and like
i said these p any and he has a pretty
sweet uh blue vw bug gonna say that yeah
he's living in a marina yeah in
california
like marina del mar and marina del rey
people that owned boats
and kept them at the marina would would
rent them out it's like little
apartments all right
and uh they weren't cheap depending on
the side of what kind of boat it was but
a lot of times it was cheaper than an
apartment and they had parking lots
there
and usually like a communal bathroom and
shower people would take showers like
you were going to the beach they had
people living like that
and and this is how this guy's living
but
what's great is that he thinks he's this
[ __ ] slick he's quite a lothario
yeah i would say he's not he's not 40s
he's probably more like mid 30s it's
just i think they yeah they looked older
back then he looks a little weathered
yeah he's probably 35.
a lot of us the facial hair and the hair
that they had kind of made you look
older
but what was great is that he takes this
young thing to his [ __ ] marina to get
up into his boat
and the dude [ __ ] his version of
[ __ ] foreplay [ __ ] it didn't last
very long tell you that but he had next
to the [ __ ] bed a picture of himself
like him
yeah he's got a shrine to himself next
to where the wine goes he sits next to
his shrine to himself and they start
drinking
wine paying homage to a picture of
himself it was [ __ ] great man it's
[ __ ] great when as soon as i saw that
like they walked in because that wasn't
where the bed was i think that was the
couch it was the couch upstairs on the
[ __ ] right up on the berth and then
they went down below where the bedroom
yeah so they come in the couch
he's making out with like this 18 year
old girl and he takes out well the best
thing too uh one of the best things he
takes that that brown leather jacket off
and there's kind of like one of those
white
uh
not a poet shirt exactly because those
are frilly but one of those like 70s
kind of
you know deals and he had that on and i
look over and i'm just like there's this
little table with like and he lights the
candles and i'm like is that his eight
by ten is that his head shot was that
was that what he was sending out like to
audition
yeah and they framed it and it's on the
table it's literally a i love me picture
and i told tom i'm like tom yeah i need
to have a black and white eight by ten
of you and i said i need you to frame it
and put it on
the nightstand next to your side of the
bed
and then put candles on either side of
it whenever i start talking [ __ ] i pull
this [ __ ] picture out of me and put
it next to me and light two candles and
talk about me
that would be funny i started laughing i
mean you totally should do that yeah
it'd be hilarious i mean yeah and to put
on like a 70s a white 70s shirt one of
those [ __ ] things like like you know
what i mean the head it was almost
looked like a [ __ ] some kind of like
a mexican pueblo type looking shirt with
the dab remember how they had it yeah it
was like that slit on the side yeah yeah
they lace in the front
and then some of them had a damn hood
and then the sleeves came out and built
they they i feel like there was a
braille down there too was there they
were woven like woven cotton or woven
wool depending on if it was a you know
if it was for cold weather you need some
kind of like smoked sunglasses yes it
looked like something a damn mexican
friar would wear like when he's at the
[ __ ] you know he's at the mission you
know and you can wear the bell
and you can wear your michael kane
willy wonka wig yeah
that's oh no okay so you need to have
that wig on and smoked sunglasses in
this hypothetical picture
and yeah we're doing this
we're going to put it it'd be funnier
we're not going to do this
[Laughter]
it would be funnier if it was like next
to the bed but obviously you can't like
really see it like on the show so i kind
of feel like we'd have to put it in the
background and then we uh you know on
special occasions we can light the
candles next to it and like have a glass
of wine to be like we're we're saluting
like yeah thomas i love me pictures but
i was just kind of like can you imagine
being that girl
and this older dude picks you up at the
turtle races as you know sometimes
happens we've all been there ladies and
gentlemen
and uh so
so you get in his sweet blue vw bug he
takes you out to his boat
and that he lives on and you go in there
and he's like hey baby want a drink and
we're gonna start to make out and then
i'm like wait is that a picture of you
is that a shrine to you
bye i'm out
it actually there's some truth to it
growing up in that area from that time a
lot of people put i love me [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
they would have pictures of themselves
doing things in and they would put them
in frames and hang them [ __ ] up in
their houses
yeah doing things you know them [ __ ]
skiing and then where they went for
vacation so i guess it's not strange to
have pictures like that you want to have
to but yeah the idea of kind of like
today i think would be kind of tacky
to put that [ __ ] into a frame and hang
it up so your guests can see it look
where i've been who gives a [ __ ] where
you've been
well the thing about it i kind of feel
like it's less weird if it's
you know because i i never knew anybody
that had because you see this in movies
sometimes especially movies starting
from the 70s and 80s like they'll go
into a character's bedroom and like you
know it's a it's a young woman or
whatever and she's putting her makeup on
in the mirror and then you see that
there's like an eight by ten of herself
yeah like a portrait like [ __ ]
glamour shots or whatever yeah and i'm
like i never knew anybody that did that
i think i did
i mean i knew people that had pictures
that kind of [ __ ] i mean i knew people
that had pictures of like them and their
friends or like you said like action
shots yeah like you know here's me and
my family like in you know at the grand
canyon or something that's not weird but
having like a a glamour portrait of
yourself i remember girls having
pictures on your i remember bedside
table seems a little strange i remember
girls having pictures of themselves
around there you know [ __ ] little
things they put makeup on and [ __ ] that
was like high school stuff yeah that
seems a little strange to me yeah but so
that's why i thought it was so funny and
i just laughed and laughed it wasn't
just just them it was like pictures of a
bunch of other people but they might
have like one of their
a photo that from one of the like
yearbook type photos or something's up
you know
yeah like you said glamour shot [ __ ]
they put that up yeah
but i mean if it's like a bunch of kind
of funny when you think about it it is
but it was just the culture of the time
i guess they would just do it because
other people would do it
i just yeah i love me pictures yeah but
that's why i laughed so hard like when i
saw this dude's thing because i said if
i like went to a dude's house
and then and he had that i just think
that would be like super fun and then he
lights the candles like very
deliberately those women would get that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] glamour shot stuff not to give
those [ __ ] photos away they gave them
away but that's not why they got them
they got it so they could have them
yeah i guess yeah i gave most of mine
away and then put the rest of my i never
had anything that [ __ ] though
well you have well i mean a lot of
photographs will be taken but never went
to any kind of damn
photography no i didn't do that either
but i mean no we but the senior photos
though yeah they came to the school
listen
they're remember back in the 80s and
even the 70s they had studios yeah they
were it was in the mall yeah malls or
some of them were yeah i never had that
done i had seen your pictures but
everybody had seen your pictures they
came and did them for free you had to
pay for them like you didn't have to buy
them but they didn't it was funny it's
like from another era that's another
culture long gone yeah back when
photography was hard to do
four throw down says is that like for
people who can't afford mirrors on the
ceiling
yeah that's what it was harry flynn's
mirror on harold flynn's ceilings was
two-way all his buddies are standing up
there and watching [ __ ] baggies
broads
underage ones that's imagine that
well you know i don't have daryl flynn
man yeah well him and his cocaine
he'd hang out at the marina too
evidently he'd take the underage girls
out on a damn boat just like this dude
was doing she wasn't now to be fair she
wasn't understood she was 18. although
he was kind of like he was wondering
because he's kind of like you look
really young yeah he's like he still
picked her up anyway from the turtle
races like i said that's
that's where they never told you that
like you know if you're looking for
somebody to like go meet people go to
the turtle races at the bar look we're
making this
we're making this movie out into a good
story this is not a good movie
it's not it's ridiculous and to be
honest with you it's it's funny it was
like entertaining but i have to say well
sort of a lot of it was actually just
really boring it's kind of boring right
although some of it was so goofy that
i was that i was entertained like those
kind of scenes were yeah well a lot of
it my mind would start wandering and i'd
check my phone and [ __ ]
and then get back to be in the middle
yeah and it's not that long it's only
like 85 minutes or something but some of
it seemed to kind of drag because like i
said the the character of wayne was kind
of like
a nobody nothing and so he was kind of
dull so you know this [ __ ] mac davis
hair and whatever and he's just going
doing this investigation so like i said
he's just like walking around
venice like talking to bombs and you
know hey did you see the monster and
you know
it was just kind of like it was kind of
dull best part of the movie for me was
just seeing southern california and
[ __ ] 78. now it got cool at the end
it got cool at the end when they were on
the boat and then the monster like
rampages and actually there was a good
scene where the monster like beats the
[ __ ] out of the car that jeff and the
scientists are in
um and like knocks the doors off and
everything and so we forgot because one
thing that angel had mentioned she's the
one that uh that
put me onto this movie
she said uh that the monster it ate your
insides out and i was just kind of like
so the whole movie i'm sitting there
going i thought like we were gonna see
some like insides you know getting eaten
or whatever but that doesn't really
happen until the end
so some of that was like pretty good for
1978 super low budget
and like i said it's not shot like it's
not like you know mano's hands of fate
or anything like that like where it just
like looks like it was shot out of
someone's [ __ ] or something it
actually looks like professionally
shot and i've heard i don't know about
the print that's on because we watched
it on toby i watched another review of
it and they've apparently put it out i
don't know if it's on blu-ray but they
have put it out on dvd like um it was
part of like a collection of like lost
drive-in classics or whatever
and um they said actually the print on
there looks looks pretty nice so whoever
shot it knew what they were doing yeah
uh you know it's not my favorite film
students it's not yeah it's not
incompetent it's it's more
like i said it seemed like the suit
looked cool for the budget it just
seemed like they were trying to pad it
out like they didn't have enough story
and
and it wasn't as compelling and you know
the acting wasn't fantastic they tried
to put all their friends in it to help
their careers these are people from the
movie business making this yeah what
they were doing it's just that they
didn't have any money yeah um
fort drew drayton fourth drawer down
that's a good question i wonder if this
is where ridley scott got the idea for
the black goop
uh i'd say no no because the
i guess you could say the idea of things
that are just kind of spawned from toxic
waste was an ongoing theme of the 70s
you know like going back to uh with food
of the gods and uh what was the other
one um the land that time forgot there
was some of that stuff where life was
being spawned out of the dam well like i
said there were some from the 50s too
yeah i thought of horror party beach
which had almost the same premise as
this or a similar premise the black goo
from ridley scott's is [ __ ]
if in
it it's explained what it is in the
leaked script before everything got all
the good [ __ ] got edited out of
prometheus unfortunately but the black
goo was a damn
biotechnology that the engineers made
because they ran out of the blood they
had this blood of a creature that was uh
got
crossbred with a damn
engineer and that blood could
evidently reboot life like it was like a
muted mutagen and they were trying to uh
reproduce
because the engineers could no longer
reproduce they gave up gender
for immortality but immortality was
wasn't working out so they were trying
to restore gender and restore biological
reproduction they were trying to do it
by rebooting themselves on these other
planets from the very beginning from
scratch like starting a process of
evolution but they ran out of the
original blood
and they tried to make a synthetic copy
of the blood which was which was uh the
black goo didn't work though and they
all died out
and they they died out killing each
other over the earth because
humans were kind of corrupted their dna
wasn't any good
and uh they started fighting amongst
themselves some of them wanted to to
destroy earth and other ones wanted to
just let it go and let nature take its
course
and there were some other planets where
they had some stuff brewing too which is
shown in in the movies like that in the
second one the alien uh what's is alien
covenant
they show another planet and it looks
like the engineers but if you look
closely it's not the engineers it's
another version of mankind that they'd
built
but uh okay great that's all i want to
say kanavatsan says hey guys have you
ever seen creature from 1985 it's not
that bad special effect dudes that
worked on this movie also did aliens i
recall yeah i think i did see that i
remember it not being great but not
being that terrible um yeah i think
that's uh yeah i've seen it
uh tammy says so i guess my large black
velvet portrait is now tacky
i hate to tell you yeah uh then camp guy
says only tacky if it's elvis and
hanging over the old time electric
hammond organ in your living room oh my
god
yeah my uh my grandfather had an organ
as well and i could i could play it when
i was a kid uh i'm you know i'm pretty
rusty now but yeah i used to be able to
play it uh strawdog 78 says if you go to
tombstone arizona and get a photo of
yourself dressed in wild west garb
actually you can get that if you could
do that anywhere well yeah if you go to
st augustine you can uh they have wild
west they have like victorian you know
they can do all those old-timey
photographs it's been a long time though
right out of fashion now i mean you can
still do it i think it's expensive
though like because i always kind of
like oh i want to do like a victorian
one but i was like yeah too expensive i
can't afford it because they charge i
mean you know they because they dress
you all up and do your hair and [ __ ]
like that so i understand 100 bucks to
get the [ __ ] done i think it's more than
that even and then like then you have to
pay for the pictures like separate but
yeah so i'm i was struggling i mean the
whole time i was watching this it's it's
weird because when you're a little kid i
was trying to like imagine when it was
that angel saw this this movie came out
in 1978 angel's the same age as me so
i'm assuming
that she probably saw this because
usually drive-in movies
that didn't they usually come to the
drive-in like a little bit later like
maybe a year later
or something so i'm assuming she was
maybe only six or seven when she saw
this movie maybe slightly older things
were released in the drive-in
yeah i know but yeah but so i don't know
so she might have been you know maybe
seven years old when she saw this and i
can see this scaring you when you're
seven because there were some i mean the
monster is kind of scary and it does
like eat your
you know left bodies it left bodies that
were all like kind of [ __ ] up looking
and like it it just eats your intestines
out and stuff
but watching it now it's just like it's
so
bad and it's just like so ridiculous but
it's always interesting to me what
scares you when you're a little kid and
then you see it later and being like
what the [ __ ] was i even oh when i was
little kid giant spider invasion scared
the [ __ ] out of me and that movie is
awful yeah it's not advisable but it's
hilarious yeah i mean my favorite part
is when that like hit gets stuffed up
that giant spider's butt and they had to
take me out of piranha
piranha kind of scared me too ham
started getting eaten by the piranhas i
[ __ ] lost it
[Laughter]
yeah well i see that's what's weird when
i was really little you know the song
monster mash
you know at the beginning of it there's
like a um like a cauldron bubbling noise
yeah for whatever reason that noise
scared the absolute crap out of me not
the song
just that sound effect i liked the song
actually but i always had to leave the
room like at the for the first and i
don't know why i still can't explain it
i don't really know like why that scared
me so much
but um but i don't know if it was like
some kind of weird frequency that was
like glitching my brain out or i don't
know i've
i've tried to figure it out and i can't
figure it out
um
but you know so i can see if you saw
this movie when you were seven and
weren't really expecting it
you know it everything's like a lot
scarier when you're a kid and you kind
of forget like all the boring [ __ ] that
happens in between because you're not
really sure what's going on this movie
was just an excuse to get your friends
on screen to help them get another other
jobs and then you sell the [ __ ] and then
the the the
the drive-ins bought it for the excuse
that you had to have something to play
because in these days the drive-in was
really just
a motel for teenagers that's all it was
well yeah so it didn't really matter if
the movie was good because no one was
really watching it [ __ ] bouncing in
the back and [ __ ] just hitting it
[ __ ] legs sticking out people
throwing joints from one car to the neck
smoking joints
high fiving your buddy in the car next
to you it was that's the way it was
so that it was just an excuse you just
had to tell your parents we got to see
this movie yeah sure
go to the movie the just part it was
safer than parking on some lovers land
somewhere and having [ __ ] son of sam
blow you away
yeah or the zodiac
or the phantom killer of texarkana there
were a lot of those
creepily
um yeah so somebody said humanoids from
the deep was good yeah i actually really
like humanoids from the deep actually
there was a moment in this the 18 year
old girl like when she gets killed i
kind of feel like you couldn't really
tell because it was kind of murky
but i we even said this this is the sole
nudity in this movie you just get to see
the girls tit for a second yeah um and i
was kind of like is that monster raping
that girl it kind of looked like yeah
but then they wanted you to think that
but then he just because he was kind of
like you know humping on her where they
got the idea for humanoids from the from
the deep and that's what yeah because i
was like is is he going all humanoids on
the
the deep of her now like on her now but
then he just like eats all of her guts
out but it's just kind of like i don't
know no i kind of hope angel sees this
and then she re-watches the movie
because maybe i don't know maybe she
thought it was so scary back the whole
day she didn't want to watch it i'm like
seriously just watch it it's like it's
really really bad
it's not well it's not that bad i've
seen like way worse like i said it's
competently made um the the monster
actually looks pretty cool
but
you know it's mostly just like a bunch
of
exposition scenes yeah important and bad
dialogue
that's all but you know
good title though yeah good poster
so 70s even and the monster the monster
on the poster that's not really exactly
what the monster looks like sort of the
chester region does kind of look like
that but the testicles the chesticles
okay look i can't talk anymore about
this
this is tom's getting cranky yeah yeah
he's getting fussy there's nothing to
this he's getting fussy
but uh yeah i mean if you want to watch
it just you know have a few drinks and
you know get a six-pack and watch it
it's on uh 2b for free so you know
doesn't even cost anything but check it
out and uh let me know what you think
and uh thank you angel for the
recommendation i hope you'll watch it
again and tell me
explain to me why this scared you so
much uh but yeah so
it was an interesting watch anyway i
think tonight
we're gonna watch uh pandorum
so we'll talk about that tomorrow
so thanks everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us this afternoon and
have a good rest of your day and we will
see you again tomorrow afternoon